では あのジャータカ物語からね
まあ一応中心にするための計画でしたけど
まあまあ ついて語るだけでね
そのそのものは語れませんだから私も
あの 一番簡単な方というのは
皆様方は自分たちが覚えている
知っているジャータカをね
私に教えてくれるならば
この物語はどういうものかとかね
それで私 そこから何を学べるかとかね
どういうものかということは説明することはできます
ジャータカ物語の中で一個一個いろんなことを教えています
いろんなこと だからどちらかというと
この西家の西家仏教との話ということをしたでしょうね
それで西家仏教といっても
ブッダの時代では お釈迦様っていうのは
このまあ王様たちと随分一般人よりも親しくいたでしょうに
だから仏教はまあタイに行ってもミャンマーに行っても
スリランカに行っても
結局はまあ王様たちの宗教になっちゃうんですね
ですから まあかなり政治的な立場っていうのは
まあ一番トップクラスの人々は当然あの
まあ知識人でもあるしね
で 仏教は大事にするということになるんです
ただ あ これは良かったっていうことで
ということで この政治論はいっぱいあります
経典ではなくて ジャータカ物語
あれ 大学で何学と言うんですか？政治学
政治学といっても 仏教が思う政治の仕方
それで俗世間的な政治のセクションはあまりはない
この性格のところ どんな性格で政治家がと政治を行わなくちゃいけないかという
そこは仏教の仕事 あの経験は 3種類でしょうね
技術的 知識的と性格的
それで性格的ところはもう一番大事ですから
そこは仏教は責任持って教えてあげたりする
それで政治論になってくると
なんか面白くないし 仏教的でもないし
俗世間の話になるし それで一つジャータカを紹介します
あまりあの ただ単に本を開けてこれにしますと思っただけで
別に厳しく選んだわけじゃないんです
あの とにかく芸が短い方がいいやって
それだけの理由で それで
お釈迦様 これ現世物語があって
過去世物語ってありますね
お釈迦様の時はコーサラ国で王様
コーサラ王様が一番大きい国なんですね
王様が あの王様の仕事っていうのは
いろいろこの裁判をやることなんですね
いろんなどこかトラブル起こったら
何か誰か不正をしたら
もう悪いこと言ったら
そこでもう裁判を行って
まあ王様 王様は最高裁判所で
で そこでコーサラ王様がある日なんか裁判をやらなくちゃいけなくて
それがややこしくて なんかみんなからくるやってるみたい
どちら側も なんかこう言うと
ああ言う ああ言う バタクンなんとか言うとかね
王様コーサラさんってすごく頭がいいんですよ
物事よくわかるんで 嘘を言った途端
これはすぐわかるんですね
しかし これはあまりもガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャもうもうどうにもならなくなったんです
とにかくお互い様言ってることは正しくないと王様は思っているんです
だから 訴える側も訴えられる側も正しくないんだったらどうしますかね
だから有罪か無罪か決めることでしょうね
これで訴える側にも判決を出さなくちゃいけないんだから
これはなりたたないんですよ
それで嫌になっちゃうよ
王様は嫌になったところで
じゃあ一旦休憩ということにして
で 宮殿に入って もうもうご飯食べたんです
ご飯食べて そのまま手足とか洗って
そのままこそっと逃げちゃったんです
じゃあ待って 待ちなさいよと
どこに行けたかというと
そのままお釈迦様のところに行ったんです
行ったらお釈迦様 この昼でしょうに
ブッダに会う時間じゃないんですね
それであんた なんでこの変な時間で来たんですか？と言ったら
まあ実相釈迦 私はまだ手も濡れたままやと
ご飯食べて 逃げてきたんだ
どういうことかというと
この裁判があって これがガチャガチャガチャガチャややこしくて
どちらでもなんかごまかし合っていて
そんなどちら側も証人やらみんなごまかしやると正しい判決できませんよ
どうにもならんとこりゃ
それで勝手にしろと逃げましたと
そしたらお釈迦様はなるほど
よくわかりますと やっぱり正しい判決できなかったら
そういう態度も悪くないんだよと
訴えはあるんですけど
裁判は開きませんと だからどちらでもすごい悔しい思いになるでしょうね
まあしょうがないんですね
それでまあ王たる者はいつでもものすごく平等で
しっかりした判決を出さなくちゃいけないんだという説法をしている
で まあ昔もそんなようなものがありましたと
言ってジャータカ物語に入ります
で それで菩薩がバーラナシの国で
まあ王様の息子で生まれて
名前はブラフマだったという名前
まあごく一般 だいたい名前同じです
ほとんど統制するんです
国はバーラナシで 名前はブラフマだったりとかね
まあそこら辺はこの覚えやすくするでしょうね
もう各ジャータカで名前が変わっちゃうと
これ大事なストーリーだから忘れちゃうでしょうね
だから役柄の名前は一応一応ほとんど決まってる
まあそこでまあ成長して大人になって
王になります 父親の後に王になったところで
しっかりと正しく政治をすることにしたんです
平等に誰の肩も取らない
判決したりすると ものすごく見事に正しい判決をしたりしている
とにかく国をどんどん幸福にして
問題ないことにしちゃったんです
それで大変なことになったんです
問題ないことで 王様の仕事を裁判やることで
また 裁判の下のところ
裁判をやっている大臣たちもいっぱいいるし
各地方にもいるし 仕事がないんです
みんな朝起きてこの仕事場に行くみたいんです
今日は誰が訴えてくるのかとかね
待っても待っても誰も来ないんですね
それでも家に帰るんだと
王様ももう最高裁判所でも
今日は何か訴えがあるのかということを最初から知らないんだから
行って座ってみたら 大臣たちとこの責任者たちはずっと座って誰も来ないんです
そういう状況になったと
これも一つ仏教で間接的に言うんですよ
もし政治が正しければ
警察に仕事はないんだよと
芋を作ることになりますよと
芋作ったり キャベツ作ったり
あるいはあっちこっちで演奏会やったりとか
もし国でね 犯罪がなかったら警察もいるしつまらないでしょうね
そうするとまあ何かベートーベンでもやってね
どこかで今度警察官の場所で代々木公園で演奏会やっても
よとかね やる世界になれないんですよね
それだったら本気で平和でしょ
だからこの医者の仕事ない
弁護士で仕事ない 警察仕事ないっていうことはもうすごいことなんです
だから失業は悪いと言ったっても
まあまあ医者には仕事なくなるわけはないんだけど
それで王様が仕事もなくて
もうじゃあどうしようもないんだと
これは私はそれなりにちゃんとやってるんだから
それはしょうがない しかし
そんなことがあっても
もしかすると私にいろいろ間違いがあるかもしれませんと
私個人に 訴えるまではいかないんだけど
王様が悪いと訴えられませんだからね
でも本人 人々の心の中で
あの王様あれやったんだけど
あれではねとかね いろいろあるかも
それ調べようと まず宮殿の中で仕事をする人々の間でちょこちょこと聞いてみるんですね
何喋ってるのかとかね
誰も自分の悪口言わないんですね
あ この連中悪口言うわけじゃない
まあ一緒にずっといるんだからね
私にお世話しながらね
まあ悪口言わんでしょうと
それで宮殿の外の軍隊とか警備とかね
そこら辺はあっちこっち歩いてみたところで
誰も何も言わない  私に雇われているんだからね
私にお世話するのは仕事でしょう
だから悪口言うわけがないやと
で 町も調べてみて見つからない
王様思ったのは 自分の悪口何か言ったことがあったら
そこを学んで自分を学ばない
自分が学ばなくちゃいけないんだと
ポイントを見てください
私は誰かに批判されたら
私はそこから自分の人格を学ばなくちゃいかないんだぞと
学ぶ世界です それでもないんだから
王様は車 馬をね 車もらって
馬を運転する人と王様だけ
出て行ったんです  大臣たちにはあまり仕事もないし
まあ君たちはちゃんと私帰るまでなんとかしてくださいと
言って地方を歩くんです
あっちこっち行くんです
誰も知らない 見たこともないんだから
王様は 地方を歩いてながら
もう誰かね 政治の悪口とか
政治家の悪口とか言ってるのかどうか
なんとなく聞こうと 誰も言わないんですね
結局はそれで行ってる
行ってるところで 隣の国がコーサラ国かな
そちらの王様も 彼の名前は
ちょっと違う名前でバルリコ
そちらの王様もしっかり政治やっていて
うまく国がうまくいって
それでなおさら何か人間が隠れて何か悪口悪口でも言ってるのかと調べたくて
その人も出て行ったんです
そこで地方で細道で この車 2つはドーンと出会うんですね
誰かがよけなくちゃいけないんで通らないんです
大変なことになったんです
でも 二人とも誰かと誰も知りません
ただの馬車 2つっていう感じで
それでバルリコ王様 隣の王様はの運転手がね
喋るのは運転手ですね
乗ってる人は喋れませんし
あんた方車どきどきなさいよと
なんで私たちは車どかなきゃいけない
あんた方どきなさいよと喧嘩するんで
運転手同士で 言うと コーサラの運転手が
あんたそんなこと言っていいと思ってるんでしょうかと
この車に誰が乗ってると思いますか？と
容姿をバラしちゃったんですね
これは本当は隠しておかなくちゃいけないのに
コーサラ国の王様だよと
隠れて乗って乗ってるの
で どきなさいよ と言ったら
この運転手さんも負けてはならんだから
あのね 私の車に乗ってるの誰かと思ってますか？と
あなたのバラの国の王様やと
動きませんよと そうするともう一対一でもうどうしようもないんですね
それでバラのぼさつの運転手さんが
うーん まあなんかいいこと考えてやろうと思って
では年聞いてやるぞと
年を聞いたら もう年上の人に道をあけなくちゃあかんでしょうと言って
あなたの王様は何歳か
生年月日聞いて コーサラ王様の青年はやっぱり年が張ってるんです
あ ダメだ これは もうダメでした
次に 家柄でも聞いてやろうかなと
王と言ったっても みんな立派な家柄でない場合もありますからね
まあ軍人だからね 戦って政治家になる
王になる場合もあるしね
家柄が立派だったら もうその人に場所を空けなくちゃいけないという
家柄を聞いてみると 家柄はみんな立派な家柄の人で OK
でもう純血で立派な家族の持っていて
では 親戚関係 まあなかなかどちら様も負けませんね
はい わかりました 国の大きさやら経済力で決めましょうと
最後に 国の大きさ いちいち聞いてみると
まあどちらでもどちらですね
またほぼ同じ 経済力を見ても
まあもうほとんど同じ
どうしようかと思う そこでこの物語は面白くいくでしょう
でも裏ですごいことを言ってます
ああいうもので人を判断するんじゃないんだよと
経済力で 年で 家柄で コネがあるんだからといって
そんなのはどうでもいいと言っていることなんです
そこで最後にコーサラ
菩薩の運転手さんが では道徳でいくしかないんか
なる人格ですね ケソって喋っていた
道徳でいくしかないか
この戦いはと 言ったら
あなたの王様はね どういうやり方で
生活しているのかと 道徳的なことはどんな人間
性格は何なのかと あなたの王様の性格を聞いたんです
言ったら まあもうよく聞いてくれたという感じで
この隣の国の王様の運転手がね
しっかり言うんです しかし
ジャータカ物語の中で一言葉
ちょっと辛口入れるんですね
あの運転手が我が王を褒めようと思って言ってるんだと
褒めようと思うつもりで非難になることを言ってるんだよということなんですね
気持ちは褒める気持ちなんですけど
結局は非難してるんだったよ
そこはちょこっと 読む人にとってはニコッと笑っちゃいますよ
だから微妙に一応ユーモアは入れるんです
そこでこの人 これから古い芸になるんですね
本物の経典の ダルハンダルアッサキパティ
バルリコムドゥナムドン
サードゥンピサードゥナジェティアサードゥンピアサードゥナエターディソアヤンラジャマッガウイヤーヒサーラティ
で 厳しい 恐ろしい 態度でかい
この凶暴な人々に対しては
我の王様はしっかり厳しい凶暴な態度で抑えて勝ちますよと
喧嘩で来るならば喧嘩で喧嘩で勝ちますよ
めげません  と モドナーモドン
すごい優しい人なら同じ優しく対応して王様は勝ちますよと
良い人ならばね 王様も良いことでその人に勝ちますよ
何にしたってのは 我が王は負けませんよってことを言うんです
悪いことをする場合は
もっとなおさら悪いことしちゃってね
抑えてやるぞと それでわかっと言う
我が王はこのようなものである
汝は道を外れなす なんていうのは開けなさいというふうに芸で言うんですね
言ったら菩薩の運転手が
まあそれから注釈書で説法はだーっと長くありますけどね
それでコーサラ王様の運転手は
あのね これはあなた徳だと道徳やと思ってる
それは非道徳なんですけどもと
全部言ったところで じゃああなたの王様の性格は何でしょうかと言ったら
アッコーデーナジネーコーダン
アサードンサードナジネ
これはダンマパダにもありますけどね
怒ってる人に対しては全く怒らないことで
慈しみで私の王様は勝ちますよと
悪いことをする人々に対して良い行為で勝ちますよと
みんな人間悪いことしてたら
王様はしっかり良い行為をして生きてると
みんなやっぱりまずいと思ってやめますから
王様の勝ちやと 次男かだりやんだね
それからケチで人を助けてあげない
何もやってあげない人々を見たら
王様はとことん与えることであって
その人々に勝ちます そのケチをなくしますよと
サッチェーナアリカワでな
人々は嘘を言うならば
王様は徹して真理を語るんだと
そうするとみんな嘘をつけなくなりますよ
それで勝ちますよ 嘘をつく人には真理を語ることで勝つ
ケチな人には施しで勝つ
怒りの人を慈しみで勝つ
悪い悪人を善行為で勝つ
我らの王はこのようなものだから
道をあきなさい そう言われたところ聞いたところで
あのコーサラの王様はさっさと車から落ちて降りて
運転手さん ああ これは参りましたと
車から落ちて 馬を外して
横道路の横に車を引いて
どうぞ通ってください
通らせたんです それで菩薩はまた菩薩の車から落ちて降りて
まあ王様と話し合って友達になって
もうなおさら法をを守って政治する方法とかいろいろ教えてあげて
まあそれから二人とも正しく悪を犯さないで
罪を犯さないで政治をやって
まあ天国に行きましたと
そこで菩薩はこの コーサラバラナシ国の王様は菩薩で
隣の国の王様は今現在アーナンダ尊者であると
そういうことだから アーナンダ尊者は弟子ですから
まあやっぱり過去世ででもやっぱり 2番目になるんです
ブッダに はい そこで政治家がどんな性格を持つべきかということは
延々と書いてはありますよ
私は省略したんですけど
例えば罰を与えるだけでは解決しません
犯罪が増えるととことん厳しくするとかね
それは仏教的じゃないんです
犯罪が増えるということは
あなた方は間違ってるんじゃないかと
例えば 学校の子供たちが自殺するならば
子供たちに文句を言うんじゃなくて
システムが間違っていることは明らかでしょうに
子供を守るべき社会が子供を守ってないでしょうに
これは何よりも罪なんですよ
仏教から見れば しかし
何もやってないでしょ
これで厳しい校則決めると
もし人をなんて言いますか
いじめたら退学させるととか
おかしいでしょう 自分たちの間違いで
なんで子供たちが罰を受けなくちゃいけないんですかね
いじめの子を退学させるとか
それではみんな怯えちゃって
いじめないことになるぞと
なりませんね 問題はそのままだから
だからそれ即世間はそう考えるんですよ
仏教はそう考えません
そんな答えじゃありませんと
だから怒りには慈しみで勝つんだと
悪は善で勝ちますよという教えなんです
だから世間とは全く反対かも
仏様 仏教徒だったら一人も人間は殺さずに済みます
半分 まあ一応大乗仏教であってもね
そういうテロ事件は起きませんよ
アメリカでも まあテーラワーダ仏教だったら世界的にも大変幸せになりますけど
そういうことで やっぱり世間は殺したら一人殺したら100人殺してやるぞと
それでもう怯えて逃げるぞと勘違いしています
でもイラク人が何も軍隊も何もないのにめげてないんでしょうに
フセインをすぐ殺しちゃったのに
それでもめげないんですから
そういうことで それで仏教的な政治論ですね
他なんか では 人格的な菩薩の物語としますけど
この人間には忍耐が必要なんです
何事にも悟るためにも忍耐が必要なんです
人格の人の一部なんですよ
忍耐 めげない 諦めない
目的に達する 苦労には負けないという
それが それの最高レベルはブッダなんです
忍耐にしたっても 6年間苦行は人間にできんだからね
それで菩薩は 1 日にしてのそんなに忍耐強になったわけじゃないんです
過去生でも経験を積み重ねてきたんです
有名な物語で カンティワーディジャータカというんですけど
忍耐のパールミタを完成したジャータカなんですね
菩薩が生まれてもう出家して
森の中に入って修行して禅定に達しているんです
それで食べ物はないんだから
葉っぱやらいろいろ食べてるんだから
体の健康がどんどんどんどんどんどん降下していく
そうするともう何年  2年
3年経つと一回ぐらいは人間いるところに来る
来て まあ普通に料理したものは食べて食べて
まあいくらか健康を取り戻したらまた森に森に入るの
そういうことでヒマラヤから降りてくるんですね
バーラナシに国に別な国ですけど
降りてきたら まあ住むところはね
一般人のところで住みませんから
王様はいっぱい土地を持ってるし
公園も持ってるし 王様の公園がありまして
そちらに泊まりました
その時 王様も時々外を出て遊びた遊びに行きたくて
この公園に行った 行って
遊んで疲れました 昼ご飯食べて昼寝しようかなと
それで一人の女性の体に膝をつけて
もう膝枕 何枕っていうんですかね
して寝ているんです 王様がいるところは
みんな人々はずっと囲まっていなくちゃいけないんです
一番そばにいるのはこのお妃たちなんですね
たくさんいるんだから
で 彼女たちはずっと王様を囲まって座ってて
まあいちいち王様に寝床まで喋ったりとかね
いろいろあれこれやってあげたりとかしていて
王様がグーグーともう寝始めたんです
そうすると女たちはもう王様寝てるんだから仕事はないしね
あっちこっちうろうろもなかなか外出られませんしね
うろうろ見ると行者を見たんですね
なんか行者が来ているんだと
言って あの女の人もまだ王様が寝ているんだからね
そちらに行ったんです
そう言ったらもう一人も行っちゃったんです
言って行者と喋っているんです
それで王様はもういびきかけながら寝ているし
みんなもうやることもないしね
周りはもう警備員は警備はやるし
問題はないし 女たちは身の回りのお世話だからね
みんな行っちゃったんです
でも あの女性が王様があの頭をつけている膝枕にしている女性はもう動くわけにはいきませんだからね
しかし 女同士だからすぐ嫉妬するんですね
逆にね この連中は真面目に仕事をしていないんだと
本当に仕事をしているのは私ではないかという気分になっちゃうんです
ほら ちょっと目が もう王様が寝ただけでも逃げるんだからサボるんだからという
そこで何したんですかというと
もう膝をもう揺らしちゃったんですね
王様が目が覚めたんです
目が覚めたら誰もいないんですね
もう仕事をサボったことはもうすぐバレちゃったんです
ものすごく怒って この女たちはどこに行ったんでしょうかと
そしたらこの女があちらにいますよと
誰かと喋ってますよと言ったら
まあ結構落ち着いている
男の前前でもみんなもう囲まって座っているんですね
これは王様から見ればもうどうにもならん
腹が立って怒りに狂って
いて 自分はそちらに出て行ったんです
そう言って怒鳴りつけて
あの菩薩にもお前何者だ？と言ったら
まあ私はこういう行者で
森から何年ぶり降りてきましたと
ああ そう 何の行をやるものかのお前はと
それはまあ 私は主にこの忍耐ということを徹底的にやっていますよと
ああ そうか じゃあお前の忍耐は何なのかで見てみるぞと言って
人を呼んでこいつに鞭で打ちなさいよ
鞭で打ったんですよ で
打ってみたらどうですかと
その程度では私の忍耐はなくなりませんと
で  303百卒で打ったんです
だから血からもう全部皮膚が壊れ荒れて血が体中出始めたんですね
そしたら菩薩は忍耐っていうのは皮膚にはありませんと言うんです
全然怒ってないんです
次に ああ そうかと言って手を一つ切っちゃったんです
あんたまだ忍耐ですかと
まだ怒ってないかと 怒らせたいんですよ
何も悪いことない人にこういうことをして怒らせたいんですね
怒ったら ほら これはあなたは偽善だと
詐欺やと言いたいし で
怒らない 手にはありませんと
忍耐は それでもう一つ手を取っ切っちゃって
それで足両足も切っちゃったんです
倒れちゃったんです もうそろそろ死にますけどね
それで菩薩はまあ そんな程度では忍耐はなくなりませんと
忍耐は手足にあるわけでもないんだと
それは王様にこれ以上やることはないし
首を切るということはもうちょっとできないし
もう別に何もやってないんだからね
それでこの自分の足でも問われているんだから
だからどこにあるのかといったら
それはまあ心の忍耐は心にあると
ああ そうかと言って 足でものすごい力強く胸を蹴って
出ていく そこまでやったんだだからお妃たちもね
大臣たちもね これはやりすぎや
王様に対する信頼がここでなくなるんですね
なくなったところであの行者のところに行って
王様に勝手にしろよと見放されたんです
そしたら行者のところに謝って謝って
どうか国に対してはなんて言いますか
呪わないでください あれはあの人が愚か者で
その個人の問題であると
我々国民は行者に対してはそんな失礼な侮辱態度はこの国はしませんよと
どうかお願いしますから
国だけは呪わないでください
仙人に呪われると大変なことになるという信仰もあります
言ったら菩薩はいえ 心配しないでください
この国民も国も王様も家族もみんな幸福で幸せでありますようにと私は祝福しますと言って
その場で亡くなるんです
それで王様はみんなに見せ合わせたところで
そのまま地獄に落ちたという話です
それで王は二度とできなかったんです
で それは忍耐 だからそれは菩薩自分自身のことだから
まあおそらく本当に過去世でそういうことは起きたと思います
まあいろいろジャータカ物語の中身から判断しなくちゃいけないんですけど
そのようなお釈迦様が 1日にして人類生命の1になったわけじゃないんですよ
かなり苦労があったんですよ
私も個人的にはどうかなと思うストーリーがあります
それは一番長いストーリーなんです
この執着を捨てるという
お釈迦様は最初にすべて執着を捨てたんですよ
そんな簡単じゃないんです
執着してること 長い間の
経験の積み重ね お釈迦様の菩薩の時代で
最後の人間で 最後に菩薩になった時
それ終わったら天国に行って
それから降りてきてブッダになったんです
だから最後のエピソード
ヴェッサントルといって
ものすごい もうそれに続いてもういっぱい本を書いたり
みんな踊りやったり ドラマやったり
いろいろやってます この物語
それは長いんですけど
菩薩がここに生まれて
王様と小さい時からも何でも人に与える
何も欲がない 子供の時からも
この趣味は自分持っているものを誰かに与えること
あげることなんです とにかくこれあげるということは
そういうなんかすごく好きなんですね
で 子供だからいいんだけど
まあそれなりにもおもちゃあげたってもう次もいいのないんで
あれどうこうなって あれは誰かにあげたとかね
どんどん大きくなってもこの性格は治らない
何かあったらあげちゃう
そこで皇太子になって
かなり責任持って政治やってます
皇太子っていうのは 一応向こうの昔の法律的に言えばこの将軍ですね
そう でも何でもあげちゃう
しかし父親がそれには何も文句を言わない
自分の息子がものすごいもう尊い人やと
だから王の家に生まれて困ってるでしょうとか思うぐらい
で で とにかく父親がね
もうとにかく何とか管理するでしょうと思って
王位を息子にあげたんだ
あんたもうこれから私は年だから全部やってくださいと
私は一応休みますと言っても性格は治りませんね
それで全部全責任自分の方に来たんだから
貧しい人を選んで選んではあげるわ
まあ国が滅びたことはなくて
国の人々はもうそこを性格を学んで
みんなをそれでけちをすることなく
ものを持ってるものをあげることにしていて
それでもう本当はこの王様のところで宮殿も何もない状態だそうです
もうあげちゃってあげちゃって
しかし 一頭の象がいたんですね
この象が白い象で もう国の宝物で
この象がいると国がいくら何でも豊かになりますよという信仰があって
隣の国の人々はなんか国がダメになっちゃって
雨が降らないわ 農作物はできないわ
貧困は ただ やっぱりあの隣の国はなんであんなに豊かなのかというと
あの象のおかげやと 菩薩のおかげやとわかってないんです
しかし あの王が王バカもんで
もう何でもお願いしたらくれるんだよと
だから あの象を我々の国にもらいましょうと
言って代表が入って それであなた方はなぜ来たんでしょうか？と言ったら
我々は隣の国から来た代表で
実はお願い事があります
何でしょうかと あの白い象が欲しいんだと言うと
大臣たちがみんなあんた何言うんで？これは国の総長であると
それで国をあげたことになるんだよ
そしたら菩薩は まあまあ
そんなこと言わなくても
せっかく来たんだから欲しいんだから言うでしょうにと言って
それで儀式を行って 象を正式的に渡してあげるんです
で そちらは象を連れて持っていく
やっぱりこれには国民が腹が立ったんです
もうなんか国の名前までもう消しちゃったような感じね
泥を塗ったようなことだから
困ったと父親に言うんですね
これではね いくらなんでも
ダメだと 父親は困って
もう息子のことをものすごい大事にするし
それで菩薩はやっぱり自分の父親がね
自分のことをものすごく大事にしているんですけど
困っているとわかって
父親に あの大丈夫です
私は王を辞めますと 国民が反対するし
国民も私の性格は治らないしね
だから一見王を辞めればいいでしょうと言って
誰にも言わないで お妃と子供を二人連れて行って山に入るんです
父親はまたもう国の面倒を見る羽目になって
山に入って ずっとお妃はもう止まらなかった
一緒にもうとにかく私はあなたと一緒に行くんだよと
で 菩薩はもう家族を父親に任せたかったんですけど
頑固なお妃でとにかく一緒に来い
一緒に行かなかったら自殺するぞと脅しちゃって
死ぬぞと まあしょうがなく
じゃあお前だけ行ったら子供たちを置いておくわけにはいかんと
だからこれ道徳的な出っぱだから
いくら何でも離れてはいけないっていうことをそこで言ってるんですよ
お金じゃないんだよと
森の中で動物で生活したっても
道徳的な人からは離れてはいけないってこと
森に入ってヒマラヤですね
とにかく生活している
そこである乞食のバラモンがものすごく
このある病気ありますね
この蚊にうつる蚊からうつる病気なんです
足なんかこの象の足のように太るんですよ
あれはなんか寄生虫が出てきちゃってね
そうなったらなんか治療がないんですけどね
そこを両足もこういう病気で
なんか足の象の足のように太っちゃって
それから傷があったりとか出て膿が出たりする
気持ち悪いんです  これは乞食で生活している
それでもバラモンだから
強引に奥さんもらうんですね
若い女の子と  親には断ることできなかったでしょうね
しかし この女はこんな汚い
醜い 見たくもない この男と一緒にいたくないんです
だから家の仕事はもうあまりやりたくない
で 怒鳴るんです 私にはできません
召使い 誰か雇いなさい
だから あのね 私は乞食で生活しているんだと
召使いは雇えませんよと
いくらなんでもそこまではみんな寄付してくれませんよと言ったら
あ だってあのウェスタンタラ王がいるでしょ
頼むんだったら何でもくれると言うでしょうよ
と頼んだらどうですか？くれますよと
乞食だから あなたも言って追い出したかったんですね
で 彼がバカだから あ そう
じゃあ王様に頼みます
召使い頼みますよと言ったところで
戻ったら王様はいない
出て どこを出て行ったかといったら
もう出家してたんだと
で このバカがもう森に行くんですよ
ずっと苦労して森に行ったところで
行って行って行ったら
子供二人が見たんで二人いたんです
男と女の子がはしゃいでいるんですね
森の中で見たところで
なんか誰かおじいさんが来るんだということで
子供たちは取って行ったら
あ こいつら私は召使いでもらうんだから
今更脅してやらないとダメやと言って
そこまたもうコラなんとか言ってもう殴ろうとしたんです
で 子供たちは怖くなって
この醜い人は見たこともないんだから
ものすごく震えちゃって怖くなって
お父さんのところに走っていって隠れて
あの父親 あの森に鬼が入ってるんだと
鬼が入ってるんだと そしたら父親は別にいいわいいわと慰めてあげて
まあ鬼はないということを知っているしね
これでこの醜い恐ろしい人が来るんです
で こういうところに何であなたは来たんです？人が来るところじゃありませんよと言ったら
いえ 私は遠い道を歩んでね
来たのはお願いすることありますから
もうダメですよと 私には今何もないんだと
果物とか何とか食べて生活しているんだよと
森の中 いえ うちの家内はね
あの召使い欲しいというんだから
あなたの子供二人いるでしょ
これくれたらどうですか
私に召使い買うお金ないんだよと
そう言われるんですね
そうすると菩薩は なるほど
私にはあげるものはあるんだ
まだもらう人もいるんだ
じゃああげるしかないんだと言ったと
じゃあちょっと待て それは私の子供でしょうにと
お家でしょう 子供は召使いとしてあげる
それで人間にはそうそうできない
普通だったら殺しますからね
相手を 仏教は では自分が甘いと感情的で
この愛着を この苦しみをね
この愛着を離れないと愛着から
この試練をね 私は通らない限りは
一切至上の救済なんかはできっこはないんだと
決めて 沖崎が果物を拾いに行っていたんです
沖崎が来る前にあげなくちゃということであげるんですよ
それはどうかなと私も個人的には思いますけど
やっぱりそれでどれほど菩薩が自分の執着をね
子供に対する執着っていうのは
どれぐらいですかね で
捨てるんですよ それでその経験をそこまで捨てることできればね
もう執着っていうのはへっちゃらだからね
執着捨てるっていうことは
そこで菩薩のまあストーリーはさらにさらに派手にするんですよ
ストーリーっていうのを伝えると派手になります
で 菩薩の前で縛っ縛ってもう引っ張って
鞭で打ちながら子供たちを連れて行くんだと
子供たちは泣いてるんだと
なんで父親が我々をこの鬼にあげるんですかと
それ 歌とかいっぱいありますよ
で 連れて行くんですね
で 子供たちも まあもう男の子がお姉ちゃん妹をね
かばいながらもう連れて行くんだと
で それ連れて行く途中で
まあそれでストーリーが終わったら仏教的じゃないんだからね
やっぱり国の方に入りますね
国に入って通っていくと
誰にもこれは信頼できない
この乞食にはね こんな扱い
こんな奴隷扱いされる子供っていうのは
あげるっていうことはありえないんだと
見てみたら ものすごくかっこいい
美しくよくできている子供二人で
そしたらすぐわかったんですね
これはもうあの王様の息子
子供二人やと それでさっさと父親に
ウェスタン国の父親に連絡して
こういうことになってます
呼んだんですね 命令して
こちら来い そしたら見たら自分の孫二人なんですね
どういうことかと思う
私の孫だよと お前らに触れる権利もないでしょうと
したら 王様 王様にはそんなこと言う権利ないんだと
私はこれはもらってる
私のものだよと 言ったらくれたんだからしょうがないだよな
だったら私は買いますと
王様が言うんです おじい様の王様が
ああ 買いますと言ったって結構高いんだよ
言ったら まあ一応エピソードとしては決まり文句とて
象の重さぐらい金貨あげるという話ですけど
おそらく子供二人の重さぐらいでしょうね
本当のところは それぐらい必要やと
子供を助けるためには
親っていうのはお金はいくらでも払いますからね
それで重さに量って金貨をね
金をあげて子供を一応解放してもらったんです
そこでまあ無事 誰にも損得なく
そこはセクションが終わるんです
だからストーリーはあるんですけど
ものすごくこの調整するんですよ
道徳はには反しないようにと
だから父親が子供を誰かにあげるっていうこと
これは法律違反ですけど
でもその場合でも そちらもピンポイントしないで
自分がどれぐらい精神的に
試練を受けるのかということは延々と書くんですよ
その場合は子供のことをガチャガチャとは言わない
子供の権利は何なのかどうか
それで これにはまあ天国も驚きましたと
ここまでやるのかと そこはリミットでしょうと
いくらなんでも で 対策点がもうこれは困りますと
で まあそれであの沖崎がね
戻ってきて もう大変なことになって
もう 意識がなくなって
もう何日もすぐ意識が倒れたりしてね
子供がいなくて で じゃあ菩薩はもうすごく親切にいろいろしてくれますから
まあそれはそれで ここで対策戦はこう考えるんですよ
あの菩薩はね 何するかわからないんだと
もし誰かが来て奥さんくださいと言ったらあげるんだと
それはもうとんでもない
やめさせなくちゃあかんと
それはとにかくやめさせなくちゃあかんと
で 退職って思うんですね
それで疑問が生まれるでしょ
起こるでしょ 皆様に なんで子供を助けてくれなかったと
なんで大人の女性を助けるんですかねと
誰かにあげたっても もう大人だから問題ないでしょうと
子供は無邪気でとんでもないでしょうと
でもそちらは別なことを教えているんです
子供あげる権利があっても
受け取る奥さんあげる権利はないんです
奥さんは守らなくちゃいけないんです
やっぱり自分の子供よりも相手のことを大事にしなさいという話なんです
世間は反対でしょうに
だからみんな不幸な家庭生活でしょうに
自分の奥さんの方が子供より心配しなくちゃいけないんです
結婚したらもう全面的に面倒を見なくてはいけないんです
子供は自分の人生だから
大人になって自分の人生やりますからね
育てれば十分です それから追い出せばいいんです
出て行けと 奥さんはそうじゃないんです
二人で一緒にいて 一緒に死ぬんです
だから 自分が他人が育てた命を預かっているんだから
その命は最後の最後まで預かった命だからね
子供と違います そういうことで
そちらの方に厳しく権利があるんです
仏教はなんのことなくそれ言うんです
世界忘れている事実を
それで退職してどうしましたかというと
もうまたなんかもっとものすごいボロボロおじいさんに変身して
また現れるんですね あの菩薩のところで
ああやってあなたはなんのために来たんですか？と言ったら
実はですね 私も一人ぼっちでかなり寂しいし
もう相手がいたらいいと思ってますよと
だからあなたももう出家でしょうしと
情けないんだとね 出家して夫婦仲良くとかね
怪しいんじゃないんですか？あんた方
本当に戒律を守っているのかどうか
それもあるし 世間は批判するかもしれませんよとかね
いろいろ言うんですね
あんた方は正直にいると思っても
世間はそう思いませんよと
だから私は考えたのは
もう私はお妃を私の奥さんとしてもらいたいんだと
だから菩薩はああ そうか
じゃあまあしょうがないと
それもそれ通りじゃんと思って
お妃あげることに決めるんですね
しかし その場合は相手の気持ち聞かないと
お妃から見れば あまりにも老人で
まあ別に女性に対しても何か気持ちあるそうにまるっきり見えません
どうせ旦那とはものすごく腹が立っていることもあるでしょうしね
おそらく  退職店だからその影響力もあるし
それで あ あなたは修行するんだから
どこまででも私の仕事はあなた
修行に協力することやと
置き...いわゆる妻として
ですから あなたはこの人と一緒に生きなさいというならば
私は何の文句も言わないで
その人と一緒に生きますよと言うんです
で それであの大作展にも奥さんを正式的に渡すのです
で 渡された大作展がまた
考え方変わって これはね
私がもらったもの それであなたにちょっと預かります
覚えておきなよ あなたのものじゃないんだよと
あなたに好き勝手に何もできませんよと
私の所有物だと だから預かってください
頼みますよと言って預かってもらうんです
それで菩薩は他の人が来てくださいと言ってもあげられませんだからね
他人のものだから そこでそこには厳密にストップかけるんですね
まあそれからまあ国民がね
菩薩は消えたところで国がうまくいかないんだと
いろいろトラブルが起こるんだと
ということでまた戻ってもらったんです
それで全部万事解決ということで
それで菩薩はまあ最後のエピソードなんですね
最後のエピソードはもうちょっと激しすぎ
そういう風にも 誰にも真似もできないすごいことをやって
修行して人格を完成してブッダになるんです
だから我々はブッダのことをブッダを尊敬することには何かあると思ったら
それは勘違い スリランカではちょこちょこっとブッダに失礼
例えば私はペンダントとかいろいろ持っていってね
タイで作っている女の子やらお坊さん
おばさんたちに使ってください
すごく嫌がりますよ 女の子たちはもうおしゃれでつけたりするんですけど
お釈迦様は胸に触れるように
とんでもない これはと
ものすごい尊敬なんです
我々 この女の体に たとえペンダントなんとかあってもね
お釈迦様の代わりだから
本当にどうでしょう だから私は
まあそれはお守りやと思ってね
ブッダに守られていると
だからあんた方も性格よければいいでしょうにと
悪いこと考えないでね
ということで まあちょっといろいろごまかしやったんですけど
まあそういう世界なんですよ
あれほど苦労して それをたった一つだけ
もうありますよ もうすっごい感動的な
もう想像できないストーリーがたくさんあります
やってきた物語の中で
それも一つの このダーナパーラミタという布施パーラミタを完了したエピソード
ずっと布施してきたんです
しかし 布施するっていうことは
自分の欲しいという自分の気持ちをなくすことですね
まあこれはもう究極でギリギリで
これ以上はもうないということ
今更なんでもう釈迦シッダールタ王子が自分の子を捨てたのかとかね
何考えてるのかと思いますけど
どこまでアホかと そこでこのこのお妃は誰ですかというと
今ブッダになった時の菩薩の夜叉ドラ夫人なんですよ
あの夫婦は輪廻の中からもいつでも一緒なんです
だから 妻は妻としていつでも旦那の聖なる道を応援してあげる
旦那対夫婦対として見ると
もう信頼できること 応援してくれること
これはすごい大事な条件で
決して裏切らないこと
それを見事にこなしていったんですよ
だから その時のお妃は夜叉ドラ夫人であったと
子供二人のあれ 誰か誰かちょっと覚えてないんですけどね
まあそういう それが一つのエピソード
まだ今日いっぱいありますけど
どうしますかね  553ありますからね
笑い